حراره تصعيد شرقي اسيا لا تقل عن حرب
ساخنه تؤجج الوضع وتخلق نقاط تحولا في دول
المنطقه
اليابان التي يحضر دسترها السلمي تكوين
جيش حقيقي تدق طبول الحرب لتعزز التعاونها
الامني وتطوير القدرات العسكريه مع
الولايات المتحده لمواجهه التهديدات الصين
وكوريا الشماليه
وجود امريكيون في المنطقه ليس بالجديد اذ
تتواجد قواعد استراتيجيه الرئيسيه وهي
مخصصه للتمركز وقواعد العمليات الاماميه
لتوفير الدعم والحمايه للقواعد
الاستراتيجيه بالاضافه الى مواقع التعاون
الامني وهي القواعد الجويه والبحريه
التابعه للحلفاء
الاجتماعات الثنائيه بين واشنطن طوكيو
تدور حول التحدي الاستراتيجي الاكبر كما
اتفق عليه الطرفان وهي الصين التعاون
الثنائي طال الفضاء ليتم تم تمديد شروط
معاهده الدفاع المشترك وتشمل الفضاء
والاستعداد للتصدي لاي هجوم عبره
الخامسه من المعاهده ما يعني ان اي هجوم
على اي من البلدين هجوم على الاخر
نحن نعمل على تعليق تعاوننا عبر كل
المجالات الفضاء الخارجي مهم لامن تحالفنا
وازدهاره الهجمات على الفضاء او منه تمثل
تحديا واضحه
لا يشبه شيئا من النهج الدفاع والسلمي
الذي لطالما اتبعته اليابان لتزيد ميزانيه
الدفاع خلال السنوات الخمس المقبله وتعزز
قدره الرد ليس فقط بالدفاع بل بالهجوم
ايضا اذا عمر العربيه